[MUSIC]
Hi, everyone, my name is Dr.
Madhu Shetti, I'm a board
certified radiation oncologist,
practicing in the San Francisco East Bay
prior to coming to the GSB.
When I have been taking care of patients,
I have noticed that many of my patients
experienced many of the problems
that I experienced growing up.
My patients had language barriers,
transportation barriers,
cultural barriers.
And oftentimes, when they would seek care,
they were afraid that they were not going
to get the best care, or they were not
going to be treated as well as others.
My team and
I strove to make sure that every patient
walking in our door felt respected, and we
gave them the best possible care with them
as a partner in every step of the process.
Unfortunately, the financial realities
of our hospital system were such
that we ended up closing the hospital, and
our community really is
the one who felt the loss.
I came to GSB with the intention of
gaining formal business skills so
that I could help other communities
keep their health care systems in place.
So that individual could get good high
quality care close to home with all
the support that they already have built
in during a very challenging time in
their life.
And as I've been at GSB taking
classes from all disciplines,
I started to take
entrepreneurship classes.
And then I became
an accidental entrepreneur.
One of the big challenges that I've seen
for patients undergoing radiation or
chemotherapy is that they
developed significant hair loss.
Their face can develop significant ashy or
pale dry looks, and
their fingernails can turn black.
And their fingers and toes can develop
severe numbness, tingling sensations,
and swelling.
Until you experience some of these
symptoms, one does not realize how much it
impacts our life and
particularly our emotional well being.
What we don't talk about is the other
symptoms that you just can't see
because they're covered up.
So many of my patients who are undergoing
radiation to the breast will have
significant redness, pinkness,
it's a peeling, a burning, and
a weeping of the tissue.
Oftentimes, it can feel like the worst
sunburn they've ever had in life.
Some of my patients have been so
devastated in the process, both physically
and emotionally of their cancer diagnosis,
that they have actually become suicidal.
And that's where it becomes so important
to have a team taking care of one to give
you all the support, both physically and
emotionally, to get through that time.
As I researched different
products to help my patients,
I never could find
anything I really liked.
Even products that are labeled as organic,
natural, or
clean oftentimes have ingredients that can
be harmful to patients during the process.
And it can be that the ingredient
can trigger a migraine or nausea.
Or it could be that the ingredients
interact at the skin, and
can actually cause worsening
of skin irritation.
And in the very worst case, it can
actually block some of the pathways for
the chemoradiation,
which will make it ultimately
ineffective at curing your cancer.
So it's very important that patients be
able to get the correct information about
the products that they're spending so much
time and money to purchase and understand.
Is it a product that will help them or
is it a product that will hurt them?
And that led to the process of
starting my company Bomb Your Skin.
So that I could make sure we could
get high quality products to
patients as they were on this journey.
I could not have done this
process without the support of my
classmates, from my teachers,
and from GSB alumni.
Who have given me feedback on
what I could do, context for
how I could execute faster, or the
resources of how do I launch a company?
How do I hire individuals?
Every step of that journey
requires special skills.
And the entire GSB community
has supported my vision, and
helped me to be able to
execute in that process.
I'm eternally grateful for everything
each member of the GSB community
has done to help me in the process
to fulfill my mission.
So I urge you to think about GSB
in your future career plans.
If you're an entrepreneur,
this is an awesome place to be.
And if you're not an entrepreneurial,
and you wanted to go into other avenues,
you very well might become
an accidental entrepreneur like myself.
Thank you so much.
[MUSIC]